das hier ist mein perfekter Döner und
das kann ich sagen weil ich mir selbst
gemacht habe und dazu gehört eine
selbstgemachte Knoblauchsoße im ganzen
Brot verstrichen guckt euch das einfach
mal an und sowas kriegt man nicht mal in
Köln im Dönerladen da muss man schon
nach Berlin weiter geht's mit dem
Dönerfleisch selbst gegrillt selbst
gesteckter Spieß woW ist duftet so
unglaublich gut nur dass ihr wisst da
stecken einige Tage Arbeit drin dieser
Laden Mischung schön mariniert ab in die
Mitte Gurke Tomate Eisbergsalat Zitrone
weiter geht's mit einer weiteren Schicht
Fleisch einfach oben drauf und zum
Abschluss Soße und ganz wichtig etwas
Schärfe und jetzt probieren wir das Ding
hmm saftig knusprig Knoblauchsoße ganz
ehrlich auch wenn ich ihn selbst gemacht
habe das ist eine 9 von 10